the words jail and prison are often used
interchangeably but actually describe
two different kinds of institutions in
the u.s. the main difference between
them is how long you stay in one and
also who is in charge so if you're
arrested for a crime you'll almost
always be taken to a jail and that jail
will be run by the County Sheriff in
your County most people never spend more
than a year there if you're convicted of
a more serious crime whether in a
courtroom or because you take a plea
deal on your sentences more than a year
or more than two years you're definitely
going to go to a prison and prison
sentences can be anywhere from a few
years to an entire lifetime and prisons
are always run by either the state
government or the federal government